jack peterson back at dodger stadium
with the chicago cubs getting a tribute
video and being presented right now with
this world series ring justin turner
just a few minutes ago said he was going
to do it along with clayton kershaw cody
bellinger aj pollock and andrew friedman
the president of baseball operations out
there on the field as well handing him
his 2020 world series championship race
builder took a no-hitter into the eighth
inning in his last start against arizona
on saturday strikeouts had been down but
he fanned a season-high 11 in that game
javier baez good news is 16 home runs
and 45 rbis the one two
baez drives one in the air left center
field back toward the wall it's got a
chance gone home run baez left center
cubs lead one to nothing
comes on the field defensively zach
davies has a one run lead to work with
as he goes to work on the dodgers who
holds waiting for the 2-1 here it comes
fastball bounced slowly to short it's
going to be gloved by soul guard running
off balance throw peck beautifully on
one hop by rizzo good play
sogar had made the running throw pujols
does not run well anymore
it was to the glovehand side of anthony
he had to make a tough pick
heyrooted first 2-2 to sogo is ripped
towards right-center field bets on the
move with bellinger he'll
[Applause]
out there in the dodgers stadium
outfield
lux at first one gone in a one-two pitch
barnes down swinging
got a chase on a curve ball
here comes the 2-2
strike three call got him on the outside
corner davies
racks up back-to-back strikeouts
second time through the order jack
peterson coming up what did he get some
kind of reception or what when they
presented him with his world series ring
before the game very popular player here
in los angeles
fans let him know it clayton kershaw had
the box and presented him with the ring
cody bellinger was out there aj pollock
justin turner and it wasn't just a flash
and a pan ovation it went on for a while
he struck him out
on a one-two from walker mueller he
swings and misses at a slider to end the
ending back-to-back strikeouts the first
two of the night from bueller
one-nothing middle three
[Applause]
first close play
dj rayburn on the call down there and
rizzo nobody better
put that tag down
i don't know
for the rizzo coming up with that ball
and getting attacked
out
how about contreras
ball in the dirt another poor pitch he
comes up with it kind of like yadi or
molina used to always do and then that
cannon to rizzo who makes the perfect
tag
yeah contreras he just he feasts on this
situation there's a guy's a little speed
down there who's going to take an
aggressive secondary he's got a
left-handed hitter up he's waiting for a
ball in the dirt where he can execute
this play
the base runner is always going to
freeze a little bit ball in the dirt and
anticipate an opportunity to take second
base
all bets are off
wow somebody had to say it
[Applause]
there goes contreras here's the throw
from barnes
and that's the ending
one catcher
erases another
[Applause]
one and two the count
to pollock the pitch
this is lined leaping grab by brian
angling toward the line
all year at the alternate site such that
it was 2-2 call strike three breaking
ball for bueller
fourth strike out of the game
3-2
destroys the bat and a bouncer to first
a race to the bag
from hayward and he's safe
levier review for sure
we'll get the first look
cut fastball up and in hayward gets a
late start out of the box i think walker
bueller got a late start because he was
trying to make sure the bat didn't hit
him
they are going to challenge
that's going to be tough because the
call in the field is safe
oh i think it's gonna stand a quick
review and is safe
seventh pitch
popped up
chris taylor
near the bag makes the catch
and ends the ending becomes leave him at
the corners we're halfway home
and now contreras with an opportunity to
add to the lead
that one drilled in the air left field
going back is
[Music]
and all of a sudden it is three nothing
davies has not given up a run or a hit
he has walked five men none have come
around to score six shutout six no hit
innings
for zach davies tonight
what a perfect spot for jake marie he's
been outstanding in his career as a
pinch hitter hubs up three to nothing
the pitch to maurizik ground ball
through down the right field line
hayward scores cubs extend the lead an
rbi single for jake mariznick so one
away base is loaded top half of the
seventh cubs four
dodgers nothing and javier baez at the
plate
he swings and drills it to short
locks to second out at second on the
first double play bickford comes in
strikes out bryant gets biased to bounce
into an inning ending double play the
new pitcher for the cubs is right-hander
ryan tapara
barnes hits out of a crouch
here comes the 1-1
this is lined right into the glove of
soul guard at second out number three
the cubs have not allowed a hit
andrew chafin is on the mound for the
cubs now bottom of inning number eight
cubs leading the dodgers four to nothing
in the year shallow left bryant drifting
one out
one out one on muncie steps in bounces
one toward first rizzo's got it steps on
the back there's one throw to second
there's two a double play
this inning comes to an end the dodgers
do not have any hits through eight
innings stay tuned
davies did not allow a hit or a run
through the first six innings
to pera
pitched a hitless seventh
chafin a hitless eighth and now craig
kimbrell
will try to finish the job for the cubs
craig kimbrell going to work on chris
taylor fastball is high ball four
a man at first cody bellinger the batter
and the o2
swinging a miss strike three there's one
one down ninth inning the kick the one
two
swing and a miss struck him out
and now one out away
from the combined no-no
last hope for the dodgers will smith
02.
history in l.a
it's a no-hitter what a night